cette proposition est un scandale absolu
non pas en soi bien que je considère que
c'est une ânerie sallèlois y aurait
encore plus les élus du terrain mais
parce qu'il présente ça comme un
chantage et c'est ça qu'il est
inacceptable on a le président du groupe
majoritaire à l'assemblée qui dit au
sénat si vous n'adoptez pas ce qui est
sur la table
en plus on changera le mode d'élection
des sénateurs pour passer à la
proportionnelle au niveau régional
qu'est ce que c'est que ces méthodes et
on a une ministre madame gourhan qui
dans l'hémicycle s'offusque parce que
les parlementaires souhaitent des quais
des réponses aux questions qu'il pose
mais qu'est ce qui est en train de se
dessiner voilà c'est vrai pour les élus
locaux on sent leur ras-le-bol qui monte
on est jugé comme responsable de tous
les maux de la terre en matière de dette
publique les collectivités c'est 10 % de
la dette publique donc il faudrait
arrêter de vous faire porter le chapeau
et au parlement on voudrait
effectivement nous cantonner et le
gouvernement dit on veut aller plus vite
plus vite plus vite mais qu'est ce que
c'est que cette vision de la démocratie